january 20 2021 president donald trump
left washington
now about a year and a half later he's
back
his address similar to ones he's been
giving painting a dark picture of the
country but one full of falsehoods
under the democrat rule
in democrat-run cities
democrat-run states and a democrat-run
federal government
the criminals have been given free reign
more than ever
before
in reality in the 10 states with the
highest homicide rates seven are run by
republicans three democrats murder in
our country is up 51
it's not the latest statistics say it's
up about 30 percent according to the
centers for disease control and
prevention
there were lies about the state of the
economy and what he accomplished in
office and the fact that he lost the
election but still there were chants of
four more years
[Applause]
not far away one of the men who would
like a chance to be the next president
former vice president mike pence made
his pitch
subtly distancing himself from his
former boss
i don't know that the president and i
differ on issues
but we may differ on focus
truly do believe that elections are
about the future
it's not just trump who's focusing on
the past attorney general merrick
garland the man who will decide if trump
should be criminally charged for his
role in the january 6th insurrection
says if trump runs again which trump
hinted at during this speech it won't
stop him from filing charges
look we pursue
justice without fear or favor
we intend to hold everyone anyone who
was criminally responsible
for events surrounding january 6
for any attempt to interfere with the
lawful transfer of power from one
administration to another accountable
that's what we do
we don't pay any attention to
other
issues with respect to that and we've
started to see more former trump
officials walk out after talking to a
grand jury in washington
indications that a trump criminal
indictment is at least a possibility
patty culhane al jazeera washington